welcome to the dave ramsey show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcast
broadcasting from the dollar car rental
studios it's the dave ramsey show
where dad is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice ken
coleman ramsey personality number one
best-selling author and host of the ever
popular ken coleman show
is my guest my co-host today here on the
air we'll be answering your questions
about life and money
ken's area of specialty is always around
career so if you're looking for a new
job you hate your mondays
this is your guy he can help you with
that his book is the the proximity
principle and we'll be talking some
about that as we go throughout the day
but here to take your questions triple
eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five andrew is in atlanta
to start off this hour hi andrew welcome
to the dave ramsey
show hey dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
so i am in my sophomore year at kennesaw
college going into my junior year
and i am lucky enough that i'll be able
to graduate
free and right now between a cd
stock market and my personal savings
account i have about 15 000
and i'm wondering how can i grow that
growth and prepare myself for when i get
out of college
well done sir what's your degree in
so i'm double majoring in both
professional sales and in marketing
oh very cool very cool i walked through
that campus not long ago
we were down there doing some speaking
in the area and i went for a walk i
ended up on the campus and walked
through all of it it's beautiful
great great location yeah it's it's
really blown up over the past few years
yeah very cool good for you well done
and great job on the money stuff
so i think you've got a pretty good mix
you've got some in savings you've got
some in investing and you're going to
come out and start your career and
uh you know that transition for housing
and
uh you know whether you need to upgrade
a car from your high school car or
whatever i don't know where you are on
that
but you're going to use some of those
cash some of that cash a little bit of
furniture maybe something other than a
beanbag chair from college
and um you know you're going to do a
little bit of that kind of stuff and
that's okay that's what's this that's
what having a nice
pool of money coming out of college will
do for you you can transition much
easier so what's your career field what
are you going into
so right now i have an in with a company
um called gartner and that's where i
would really like to start my first job
at but
as of leads that's kind of the only one
i'm having right now
i'm looking for an internship this
summer but i'm not sure i feel like i
have all this money sitting around and
not sure
what to do with it you're it's not being
lazy it's there for a pad
and it's there for attraction it just
gives you margin it gives you the
ability to make these transitions
without having because let me tell you
if you're broke you'll take any job
and oftentimes oftentimes the wrong one
right ken that's exactly right you don't
want to be desperate
you're in a situation where you've got a
pretty good idea the type of work you
want to do and the type of company
so what you want to do is you want to
get yourself some more options right now
i love that you want to intern
i think that's one of the best things
that college students can do because it
allows you to clarify and verify and
that's the process of getting in the
actual field itself
and rubbing shoulders rubbing elbows
with the professionals that are doing
the work what's it look like what's it
feel like day to day
and that's the clarify and then as you
begin to experience and immerse yourself
in this field that you think you want to
go into by doing that dave
then the verify takes care of itself the
head
and the heart the head's logic and then
the emotion of the heart to say
ding ding ding and that process is
really important so i love the idea of
interning and then i would come up with
two or three other uh company targets
you need more than one option so that
you can
start working the proximity principle
what relationships do i have that allow
me to know
somebody just anybody in that building
to begin to learn more about the
company's culture that's another thing
dave we get this question a lot on the
ken coleman show
a lady called just uh just in the last
hour and said you know
how do i know how do i i'm leaving
one state to go to another state my
current company's going to let me work
remote for a while
i eventually i just can't be on my own i
want to work in an office environment
which i understand that that's how i'm
wired
she said but i have such a great
experience with the current company how
do i make sure that i don't
get on board with another company and
the culture's terrible i said that's
easy
start talking to people who know people
who work there believe me they'll tell
you about their company
the good and the bad now you've got to
learn how to parse that out and go
is this a disgruntled former employee
but you can do it
for employees you don't talk to them
they're former for a reason that's right
you want to talk to people who work
there
you want to see what their vendors are
saying about them and you can find out
that a company's healthy
it's not this big giant stick your
finger in the air and it's a big
risk there are ways to find out if a
company has a healthy culture and you're
talking and here's who worked there just
because somebody posts something on
glassdoor
does it mean it's right there's no
there's no accountability of that
very careful no accountability on that
at all that's horrible
yeah i mean we've had horrible
experience with glassdoor because people
put stuff on there that they just make
up
and and they have nothing to do with
every company's got people that have
left and didn't like it
well you can promise you they have here
that's absolutely so you've got to talk
to people who actually work there
and and you're going to hear the right
things and then you go okay this is a
healthy culture and again
no culture is perfect stop making that
an excuse but i hear that a lot
people a little really scary how do i
know that's you know do your homework
and and here's the thing interview yes
if you can get an in person and
you can walk in a building you can feel
a vibe
you feel the spirit of what's going on
are these people all heads down and look
like they're in a cult and they've got
zone going through their eyes are they
running around happy and high
high-fiving and
getting work done and productive and
looks like there's a little some
giggling going on you know i mean
you know that that's what you get when
you walk through here oh sure and so
obviously it is not a
you know some kind of crazy you know
cult thing going on that's just
absolutely
yeah well it's great about this people
can say whatever they want about ramsey
solutions then you can come here and
actually walk through the building
and experience it for less than five
minutes and you're gonna find out really
quick it doesn't match up to anything
that you would have heard and so that's
true
uh for folks for yourself is the point
that's
it yeah get the eyeball test you know
yelp had this problem when they first
came out
they lost all credibility yeah as a
rating service because
you know the restaurant across the
street would write a negative review
on their their competitor and and
anonymously and just make up crap
right and fill up the yelp with all
negative and so they they were not
vetting their their inputs and so
you know it's like i told somebody this
week if that if the national enquirer
runs a story that tom cruit that they
interviewed an alien that tom cruise had
had sex with does that make it true
exactly well how many times has this
happened to you dave and i i trust my
friends and family members and
co-workers here
but but this has happened to me many
times where someone said ah i'd have a
great experience at that restaurant
and and it affects me yeah and i say to
stacey i go
well i mean so-and-so said and i've had
this conversation
i'll tell you i just really want to
check it out for myself and i go
and it's not that my friend or family
member who had a different experience is
wrong it's their experience
it's through their perspective it's
through their lens maybe they didn't
think the menu was any good but i
thought the menu was great or they
didn't think the
customer service was great but my
experience was great maybe it was a
waiter that had a bad night or maybe it
was a doofus
you know hostess or whatever here's the
whole point here that i'm making
even though we may hear something even
when you go get feedback from people
that you trust
go walk it you have got to experience it
i want to go to the restaurant i'll tell
you what i
want to go to that company and then
you're going to find out if the
culture's right that's right
so you don't have to be afraid about
that no it's not a mystery
if you have your antennae up yes and you
just walk around with a smile that's
right and just be observant
if you can physically get to the company
i mean these days through the heck knows
that's true if you can physically get in
the presence you'll get a spirit off of
it that's exactly you can trust
that yeah it's trustworthy that feeling
is trustworthy yeah it really is
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
cliff and i joined christian healthcare
ministries because we really liked the
concept
of christians sharing each other's
burdens
and we really experienced that firsthand
when cliff
was diagnosed with heart disease it was
just such
a relief to know that financial burden
was going to be taken care of
chm is the original and longest serving
health cost
sharing ministry get started today and
check us out at
[Music]
chministries.org
[Music]
thank you for joining us america ken
coleman is here open
two phones five two two five you can
join him on
uh just under 70 radio stations around
america now carrying the ken coleman
show every day
and of course it's a podcast it's on
sirius xm and everywhere else you can go
to kencolman.com and download
all kinds of helpful treats to help you
get your resume looking right
to get your interview started steps to
the interview the whole thing everything
about career he's america's career coach
sarah is with us in saint louis hi sarah
welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi hey what's up so i have a question
i graduated undergrad my undergrad
degree
debt-free and i'm currently working on a
law degree paying as i go and working
full-time so that i can graduate
debt-free great but i'm also
contributing to my 401k and i'm
doing the full 15 percent of my paycheck
and my company has a good match i've
seen some articles online
that seem to make it appear that the new
administration
doesn't look favorably on 401ks and
wants to
possibly you know diminish them so i'm
wondering if i should do anything with
the 401k that i have now
no uh i have not seen that
trend uh by anything credible uh
but i i have no idea what the biden
administration is going to do
and uh we do not have the benefit of
checks and balances in that they can
pass anything through a democrat
senate democratic congress so i don't
know what they'll pass
um i i would think
it would be very difficult and political
suicide to screw with the
largest wealth building tool in america
but who knows
these are strange times so it doesn't
mean though that i wouldn't put money
into it
in anticipation of some bizarre
political event and by the way that
would be
the definition of a bizarre political
event for him to do that
in years past would have been political
suicide today i don't even know what
that means
but um uh so i i
i used to say things like oh no way they
would never do that but i have no idea
in this world right now what they're
gonna do
but i don't i i will continue to put
money in my 401 k
until i have different information than
i have today
which i don't have any information
that's credible that makes me think it's
one of the
you know biden administration's top
priorities to do away with
america's primary wealth building tool
yeah i i'm not seeing anything on that
uh that would not be an overnight
uh result that would there would be some
serious serious conversation about that
and an uproar to say the least uh and
and so i don't think you need to be
fearful at all i agree with dave on that
but yeah i mean you know
get beyond that 401k you know here you
are you're off and running and you're
you're cash flowing uh your education
you're going to do very very well
and so begin to look at you know the
diversified plan that we teach here at
ramsey solutions you know
retire inspire to be a great book for
you at this stage to begin to see
what's the future look like and what are
all the ways that i could
uh prepare for the future but no don't
don't be in a state of fear right now
and that's part of the problem dave is i
understand there's uncertainty for
75 million americans let's just be
really honest you have a very divided
country and an election that obviously
all kinds of stuff going around it and
and i can tell you this
i'm not a spring chicken but i'm not an
old man either but i've been around
enough to watch a lot of elections and a
lot of change in power
and uh one thing that i just want to
tell our audience
your side is not as pure as you think
they are
and the other side's not as evil as you
think they are either so relax
you don't need to look to washington dc
for your future
you don't and stay the course keep doing
smart
things and don't freak out fear is never
a great place to operate from
yeah i can promise you this if they do
do away with the 401k
we'll be here to help you figure out
what to do that is true and we will be
ready we'll show you
what to do that is true and uh there's
something to do there's always something
to do there's always
a way to do things but i really truly uh
i would be shocked and amazed but i will
caveat that with saying i have been
shocked and amazed that's right years of
what these
characters will pull off on both sides
of the aisle open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five tyler
is in abilene texas hey tyler how are
you
i'm doing great how are you dave great
man how can we help
my question for you today um i graduated
college this december
uh probably the worst year i could
imagine to graduate college
um but um that would have been 1932 but
yeah
yeah i just started a job i got my
bachelor's degree in youth ministry
uh got a job immediately after college
and i'm making pretty decent money
um this january i started the baby steps
and today i just finished my thousand
dollar emergency fund
great um and my question for you is as i
start baby step
two there's a couple things in my life
that are coming up that i don't know if
i should
pause baby step two to let these things
happen or
whether i should just go ahead and go
with it uh the two things that i'm
really looking at is i'm getting married
in june
and i would like to end up doing my mdiv
and seminary as well
so i'm kind of looking at those two
things right now as well how much debt
have you got
um let's see i got about 2 000 on a
credit card
uh 21 000 on a car and 35
000 on my student loans and what are you
making
i'm making 44. what's she make
she's not making anything she's in her
last year of her undergrad
and she'll be a kindergarten teacher
starting
next august so we imagine she'll make
anywhere from
35 to 45 depending on the school
district
why do you want the mdiv oh well for my
job
it'd be a pretty decent pay raise um and
really i just
really want the education mainly out of
that your church gives
raises based on your degree well
on average it it makes it easier the
percentage goes up
the annual uh raise the percentage
yes yeah that's interesting
it's unusual it is i the reason i ask
the question
is um and this is my position on all
degrees
if it's the only way and if it's the
best way
then we make that a huge priority but in
this situation
and there's nothing wrong with you
wanting the mdiv i think it's great that
you want that further education
but i would not press pause dave on the
baby steps i'd press pause on the mdiv
the individual will
always be there absolutely you need to
get these debts cleaned up
i think with your combined income you'll
be able to clear these debts pretty
quickly i don't
know what her debt was we didn't get
into that but um you have a
75 80 000 household income 85 000
somewhere in there
and you can attack these debts uh and if
a twenty three
thousand dollar car which is ridiculous
in your setting
um is in your way between union and divs
and move to a five thousand dollar car
that's right
and get down uh it's too expensive a car
for where you are today you're getting
married in june going to double your
household income soon so i'm not going
to make you sell it
or suggest you have to sell it to get
ahead but it was a stupid purchase
yeah given the amount of debt that you
have uh
you're coming out as a youth pastor so
anyway that that's uh but no the mdiv is
definitely on hold
yeah and um and you know again
it's there's furthering your knowledge
is not a bad thing no
furthering your knowledge that creates
extra income moves it up as a priority
that creates a lot of extra income or is
the only way to enter in
a career that's a whole different thing
that's correct but
um you know this falls very close to
uh the s the area of luxury
knowledge absolutely it is at this stage
at this stage it is yeah
so uh i mean it's not holding you back
and it won't by the way in ministry you
know in in
in the american society i i can't speak
to the rest of the western world
uh but in american society dave we have
put a premium on education
to where it is a normal thought and we
don't begrudge tyler on
this question but it is a normal thought
to go well the next step
the master's degree in whatever industry
it is
it is it is so worth it it is worth the
debt because of what it's going to do
for me long term
and that is just it couldn't be any
further from the truth
uh these education folks are smart they
got marketers
and they have marketed this message and
we got to be careful it's not worth it's
become a cultural icon it's a cultural
icon it's an idol if i could say that
and we got to be careful it's not worth
the price of going further into debt no
ever no you're going to cash flow that
puppy or don't do it at all yep
in any event so any possible scenario
good question sir congrats on the
upcoming marriage this is the dave
ramsey show
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country or have a
better life
the army national guard can help get you
there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
[Music]
so
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today here on the air this is the dave
ramsey show jake
is with us jake is in lansing michigan
and it says on my screen jake that you
are
debt free congratulations
thanks dave absolute honor to be on the
program
well thank you good to have you how much
have you paid off
paid off just over 38 000
in student loans took me about two and a
half years
um started making about 18 000
all the way up to 56 000 i'm working in
it now
and it feels so good to be debt free
good for you man how old are you
26. way to go excellent so what kind of
debt was the 38
it was all student loans man
so what inspired you to get this going
two and a half
years ago i've actually been a long time
listener i have memories
riding around in the car with my dad
when i was about eight listening to you
so
uh just always was always a dream of
mine my dad pushed me i want to thank my
parents for pushing me to do it and
yeah very cool well so when you
graduated you just took off and did it
or what
pretty much i mean i was living the rice
and beans beans and rice for
for two of those two and a half years
you know that
i went from building fences to working
in i.t so yeah it was
just went and did it wow tell us about
that journey building fences to breaking
into the technology field what'd that
look like
yeah i uh i graduated had a tough time
finding a job
i just needed money so i took a job
building fences it was i was building
fences for ten dollars an hour in the
freezing cold i was like this sucks
took another job took another job at
a corporate office here in lansing doing
data entry worked my way up
got an opportunity to jump over to the
i.t
side cut my teeth there got another
opportunity
hopefully i'll move up again just just
keep hustling my way out
i love it well i tell you there's
nothing like a ten dollar an hour job
in the freezing cold manual labor to get
you motivated all right dave
i don't got to get your butt in gear
won't it yeah well done jake
well done okay now your friends are out
there you're talking to them
they got 30 or 40 000 worth of debt and
they say hey man how'd you do that
what do you tell them the key to getting
out of debt is
i just point them to you dave
yeah but what did i tell you to do that
you went and did
oh yeah you got i mean you gotta cut
your lifestyle you gotta you gotta be
good
gazelle intense you gotta just attack
the debt because it feels so
good on the back side of it so will you
go back in debt
heck no what about what about you what
about your car your next car
no i've got i've just i've just
completed baby step three i'm saving up
for a down payment on a house
hopefully my car will make it a couple
years but if i need the cash it's all
cash
there you go wow well done sir i love it
i'm proud of you congratulations very
good
and say it feels good on this side huh
oh it feels
fantastic making that last payment i was
like oh wait lift it off my shoulders
well i'm proud of you man well done i
know your parents are as well
excellent excellent job all right we've
got a copy of chris hogan's book for you
everyday millionaires and it will
certainly show you the next chapter
because that's the
that's the track your own brother you're
going to be there before you know it
excellent job very cool all right jake
in lansing michigan 38 000 paid off in
two and a half years making 18
on the fence line up to 56 in the it
world
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three two one
[Applause]
very good excellent job
very well done i suspect dave that
somebody else in lansing heard that
that was next-door neighbor anyway our
question of the day comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run every month you'll save even more
use the promo code ramsey to get the
best possible deal
today's question comes from melissa in
pennsylvania she asked i feel like i've
lost my passion
in my current career field of i.t how do
i tell if it is from burnout
or a loss of interest for the work
itself okay i love this question dave i
get this all the time so let's first
start with
it burnout it's not from burnout so
burnout is a symptom
okay if if if if i've got an injury in
my knee
uh this the problem isn't the actual
pain
i gotta find out what's causing the pain
so i go to the doctor
and we're gonna dive in and so when i
hear somebody talk about burnout burnout
is a very real feeling folks it comes
with mental and emotional
effects it can also have physical
effects so i don't want to in any ways
minimize it but there are
causes of this feeling of being burned
out if you're alive
well you're not burned out when you go
into eternity well the flame is gone so
i've got great news for you
melissa you're not burned out but this
loss of passion
that's one of the five causes of what i
call dave build up on the heart
if i keep coming in every day and i
don't have any juice for the job
i don't love the work eventually it just
becomes a utilitarian function it's a
j-o-b
and i get bored which is another cause
maybe she's dealing with toxicity in the
workplace it could be a lot of things
but when someone says
i've lost passion so what we have to say
is okay why
if you lost it you had it so if she was
talking to me on the ken coleman show
she called in here today and you could
call and i'll talk to you if that's you
right now here's what i'm going to say
if you had it
let's go back and look to the time when
you had it when you had passion
what's changed and therein lies the
answer to when someone says i've lost
passion we go
well why do why do you not love it
anymore well it could be because
a variety of factors environment in the
office
it could be that um that you're bored
you haven't been challenged in a long
time and you've actually mastered
competitiveness yes and when you first
started it it was the zeal
but now you've done it ten thousand
times it's repetitive and we as humans
need
progress so um i would not assume
melissa
that you've lost passion for it work
let's find out what you loved most about
it at the time what you still love doing
what work you love to do
and we walk through this with people the
sweet spot is at the intersection of
talent passion mission talent's what you
do best
hard skill soft skills passion is work
you love to do it's not about notoriety
or pay
you just love the work itself and then
finally mission
well all work creates results melissa
and so what are the results that you
want to produce and here's what i can
tell you dave
um she's not currently producing results
that really fire her up she doesn't see
them she doesn't tell you it's a problem
in the technical world it is
and we've solved that at ramsey and so
we're getting some of the best tech
and uh you know web architects platform
designers everybody else in the world
are coming here
some of the best in the world because
they get to see that when they write a
line of code when they lay something out
it results in this person being helped
and so many times the tech department
gets stuck in a basement
and they're just they're just uh they're
just salt mines that's right
and and they work them a thousand hours
a week and work them into the ground
instead of letting them have a home life
and uh they're just treated like robots
like a commodity that's right you burn
them up and throw them out burn them up
and throw them out
and that's that's often done in that
world we've we've gotten we've been the
benefactor at ramsey
by of hiring people trying to get away
from that so
it could be the repetitiveness it could
be that just leadership has
made the mistake is a gentle way of
saying it of not
letting the tech guys and gals see
how their work is connected to the net
result of the company
and that's why you always go back to am
i creating a result with my work
that i can look at and say this matters
deeply to me
because i can see the significance that
it's having in the workplace you know
folks this is a stark reminder but i'll
just i'll just lay this out there dave
because we got millions of americans
that are miserable on mondays
and and back in in in the one of the
worst things about the concentration
camps
uh wasn't just how they treated the
prisoners physically dave is that they
broke them down mentally the way they
did it is they would have them do
meaningless work
move a pile of bricks from one side of
the concentration camp to the other
and i've read the stories from survivors
and that killed him as much as anything
this lack of meaning i'm doing
meaningless work
you've got to pay attention to this
folks this is frankel talked about that
his book was literally titled in search
of
meaning there we go that's it this is
the dave ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today here on the air
no parent ever wants their child to
experience the panic of being
unprepared for an emergency but teaching
your teens how to be smart with money
yeah that can be tough well we got your
back
with our digital self-study courses you
can rest assured your teen will know the
right way to handle money no matter what
curve balls
life may throw that them down the road
the best part is you don't need an
instructor
your team if your teen has a tablet a
computer they're all set
parents if you're riding around
listening to the dave ramsey show the
ken coleman show the rachel cruz show
and you're trying to get your kids to
listen in go ahead and take the next
step and put them in the class
dave ramsey.com self study
you can learn more about different
courses that we have available for high
schools
and for high schoolers and for middle
schoolers as well
that billy is with us in dallas hey
billy welcome to the dave ramsey show
thank you good afternoon mr ramsey and
mr coleman it's a real pleasure to speak
with you today
you too sir how can we help well
i guess a little background information
my wife and i are both retired
and we were blessed to be able to
completely build and pay for a vacation
home a number of years ago
wonderful we actually we actually bought
the real estate the property
about 30 years ago and then built a
vacation home there
about a decade ago and as
life has progressed we decided last year
to sell that
vacation home it was never used as
rental property it was just a family
getaway
currently and for the last several years
my wife and i have
been blessed beyond belief and are able
to live on
nickels and dimes pretty much and i've
never been able to find an answer to
how to calculate the capital gains on
the sale of that vacation home
or if capital gains will actually
need to be paid there will be whenever i
file taxes
yeah you can just check with your tax
advisor or check a tax elp at
daveramsey.com but your basis is what
you paid to build it
plus what you paid for the land and you
because you've not
you've not appreciated it at all no sir
that's correct but what i've seen is
that
capital gains taxes are zero up to a
certain level of
income for a married couple filing
jointly and
so i guess my question is does the sale
and the proceeds of that vacation home
count as income during that particular
year that it was sold
i don't know i'm not very good at taxes
i'm sorry billy
uh i think it does as far as i
understand but i want you
i really want you to get some
professional advice on this um
so you don't have investment income
we we do have uh retirement
we we have retirement income but we've
not taken any proceeds from the
retirement income yet so none of it's
none of us taxable right now no any of
my iras and
that sort of thing i rolled over based
on your advice i rolled over my 401k
and the the pension plan when i retired
about six and a half years ago
into uh iras but we've been
again fortunate that we've not had to
take any procedure withdrawals from
those retirement accounts
yeah so my guess is it's going to be
taxable
at a capital gains rate i do not know
whether the income is going to count i
think it will count
and we'll drive you up into that and so
you're probably going to have a 15
capital gain on the actual gain what do
you think you've got in the property
well we uh we actually sold it for 360
000 and as close as i can calculate our
um
what we paid to have the home built and
pay for the property
is about 200 000. okay so you got 160
000
and the only question is how much is
taxes going to be on it or how much of
it's going to count towards this
equation
yeah yeah i i the truth is i i
you know i know you i know you have a
gain there i don't know with
you having virtually no income whether
you're gonna be able to duck under the
15 or not
and um that that's a technical tactical
question and so i'm to have to send i'm
gonna have to tell you to do what i
would do
which is i would have to pick up the
phone and call my my tax guy
and my elp my endorsed local provider
for taxes and get some help with that
and that's what i'm gonna have to have
you do i'm sorry
i wish i knew the answer but we didn't
you you do know how to calculate your
gain you've got that figured out
and it's going to be at 15 if there is a
gain or nothing
if you're low enough and it doesn't
count and this
doesn't drive you up above that limit so
i i don't
i don't know how that can i don't know
how that works exactly sorry
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five ken i should have
let you jump in because you really
you're like a tax expert right yeah yeah
yeah i'm a tax expert as an is that i
like to not be taxed and i think that
i i'm a tax expert in that i don't
believe we should be taxed very much at
all and and yeah
it's all about political opinion is
where i stop
i'm an expert on my opinion about what i
think that's it
but hey that's why we have elps by the
way i think it's a great illustration to
say
even with you it's complex some of the
stuff you've got going on
we all need attack tax experts this is a
weird talk show because
you don't have many talk show hosts that
actually will tell you i don't know
that is true that's an unusual truth in
broadcasting unusual
here talk radio because they want you
know those of us on the microphone are
supposed to know something about
everything
all right susannah is with us in tampa
florida hey susannah how are you
um i guess i'm i'm not doing as great as
you are you guys
sound great um but i'm a little bit
embarrassed and also distraught because
my question
is not as wonderful as all the other
questions
everyone's very lucky no it's okay
what's going on how can we help
due to covid and due to being laid off
from my job 11 months ago
i've had to cash out my insurance policy
my life insurance
and my one and only son that i was
saving for
um i do have an ira 67
000 and i do have my about maybe 2 000
in cash put aside i do
have one cd small one
a lot a lot of credit cards due to covet
but my
my question is um i'm having difficulty
getting another policy at my age
obviously you can tell
65 and
and it's mainly for my son but also to
pay off
you know if i have anything left over i
don't know how old is your son
he's 23. and why are you required to buy
his life insurance
no it's my life insurance that i wanted
to leave for him
no you don't need to do that see
i did it because and i won't say the
last name
i watched someone called susie which you
know who
said you don't need life insurance to
keep paying
300 500 a month
you should cash that out and put it in a
cd
or something well me and susie agree but
well i'm glad to hear that but i'm
having difficulty finding
a place to do that yeah but the point is
you don't need to buy life insurance on
a 23 year old and you don't need to buy
life insurance on you to leave the 23
year old something
the 20 year old 23 year old needs to
make his way in his life and
and not leave his mother with this
burden right now
so mom you don't have that burden that's
easy now uh and you don't even need life
insurance on you you've got enough to
bury you if something happens
and so you're good uh so now all we've
got to do is worry about getting your
career up and going because you're
starving to death because you haven't
been working
and credit cards which haven't slept
since last february
what were you doing what kind of work
were you doing
i believe it or not i was working at the
airport um
originally working with an airline got
laid off with that and then moved on to
pulling a check and boarding passes for
the passengers in front of tsa
[Music]
and that's gone now too gone okay
so i'm doing uber when i can
okay and finding trying to find a way to
take credit cards off and not eat too
much yeah well
the reason you have credit card debt is
not covered the reason your credit card
debt is covet affected your career
you lost your income now that is a
reason that people get into that and
that's for real so
what we've got to do is hang on i'm
going to have uh kelly pick up and we're
going to get you on to ken coleman's
website let you download some things to
get you some ideas on some things to
start creating some income
and get some interviewing going because
what you have more than anything honey
is a career crisis
you have an income crisis that's right
so if we can get that fixed the rest of
this stuff is going to start to fix
itself
and quit supporting the 23 year old
period
no circumstances is that okay especially
with all the things you're facing
you've got enough irons in the fire
without him telling him to get it get on
with his life little pig
that puts us hour the dave ramsey show
in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it
in the meantime hang on ken coleman and
i'll be here
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the dave ramsey
show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i am dave
ramsey your host ken coleman ramsey
personality is my co-host today
we're talking to you about your life and
your money thank you for joining us
the phone number here is triple eight
eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five
john in indianapolis indiana starts off
this hour hey john how are you
good dave it's a pleasure to talk to you
and ken you too sir what's up
so um i got a question about wills um
my wife and i had originally set up a
will for us
back when our oldest was originally born
uh 17 years ago and
since that time and it was set up where
everything would go into it if both of
us died everything would go into a trust
for the
for the kids and they would start to be
to get them
at different ages starting at like age
21 and then 25 and 27
they would get a portion of it and now
uh since then um my wife passed away
and so it's just me and looking at uh
the amount
that is going to be in the estate at
this point in time
uh with insurance it's
it's gonna be over four million
and i've heard you talk before about
putting stipulations in
that you know i don't want the last
thing i want is to
enable my kids to be trust fund babies
and you know i want them to be working
hard
and so how do i go about putting in
stipulations that they need to meet
certain criteria you know as far as
you know in general i want them to be
living for the lord
i want them to be managing money well
about how do i go about actually
putting that in and who makes those
decisions
um well that's uh you'd have to sit down
with an estate planning attorney
and uh you develop terms of the trust
and uh uh ours has gotten
the more the larger it's gotten the more
complicated it's gotten
uh and and so you know it just depends
on how
much control you want to try to exhibit
through this process
and the more control you want to try to
exhibit the more complicated it gets
obviously
and so you know uh uh
we put ours in with a family
constitution there are three kids in the
trust
and if any uh any one of the three
aren't abiding by it the other two
can uh you know cause the trustee to
take action
and remove them from the benefits of the
trust
and then there's a process by which they
can come home
if they're prodigal you know and that
that they could be redeemed and put back
in as well so we built all of that
in and then you know you've got to
detail
out the the timeline on that and and try
to
uh are not the timeline but the the uh
the guidelines
by which someone could be uh exited
from the benefits under what
circumstances because
you know what happens is that things go
sour
uh after you're gone and one of these
siblings uses it as a weapon on the
other one and then you've just got one
of these things that's just a lawsuit
that eats up all the
money and uh we've seen that with lots
of
family stuff that gets in the news and
um
i can think of three different families
right now that i know that are
uh household their their businesses are
household names
and the estate nastiness got into the
news
and so you just want to be real clear
the biggest thing you can do is just
handle all this while they're alive
while you're alive i mean
uh you know if you got one of them off
the rails just go ahead and decide
now you know that they're not they're
not going to be in it
and um you don't want to [ __ ] i'm not
going to fund your cocaine
you know i'm not going to fund your
trust fund and baby activities you're
going to be productive citizen
uh you're going to be walking with god
you know and i agree with you on those
things and that's what we put in ours
but it's got you know it's very detailed
it was rather expensive to build because
of the lawyer's time involved
and it's a little bit unusual what we
did but um
but i'm just trying to cause the money
to be a blessing and not a curse
because it's a curse if it enables bad
behavior and that's what you're
concerned about right
yes absolutely yeah okay so how old are
you
uh my oldest is 17 so 17 15 and 10.
yeah okay well they're still pretty
young so they're a little
yeah they're a little young to know
really how well
you know they're gonna yeah you'll know
a lot more ten years from now for sure
so uh right you know i'd probably keep
it pretty clean and simple right now
and then as the wealth increases and as
they get older and you've got
indications i might get more complicated
then
it's actually what we did um okay
i mean uh the problem is i mean with the
real estate portfolio
and the size of ramsey and everything
it's hundreds of millions of dollars
and so it's not um you know it's not a
simple thing to say
uh when ours was 4 million we were very
simple
and that's not that's not to say 4
million is not a lot it's a lot
but um but the problem with hundreds of
millions is you can run two generations
or three generations
[Laughter]
so i got more and more paranoid about
doing the right thing by my family
as we've as it is has grown so it is a
challenge
the way you set that up and i don't want
to get into the the family business but
but do you have a trustee and so the the
children would if two
if one was uh misbehaving the two would
make the case to the trustee
yeah and so what happens if the trustee
has a heart attack and dies do you have
there's a substitute trustee you have
all of them
all trust me i think through all
trustees always have a substitute
trustee that's what i think in all trust
no attorney that's worth their salt let
you build a trust with a single
good person that the whole thing stands
on that person and then yeah
yeah and you can you know you can cause
that trust to e to be changed out
right also uh but but they still have to
serve that function
is it much like an arbitration situation
where that trustee i mean there's
there's there's minutes there's
absolutely the trustee i mean
it can't kind of determine how they want
to run it they have to build back up
that they did
they have to go by the terms of the
trust right they don't get to make it up
right
they don't get to make up their own
rules and so this is not a there's not
left much left to interpretation either
if they don't go by the terms of the
trust they start being personally liable
a pursuit by the beneficiaries of the
trust which would be the
the in this case the kids so um
but the big thing the way you know once
the kids are older now his are younger
yeah but once the mine are all adults
with spouses and kids of their own
and so you're just talking through this
stuff all the time it's not
like they've discovered all of this was
done after i'm gone
we have this big davis gonna die this
year meeting every year
and if dave dies this year here's what
it all looks like and we review
every bit of this so they that one more
time they've got to dial into their head
what the intent was
and how things should work it's going to
be weird sitting in that meeting for you
monty python meeting i'm feeling much
better it's just a flash were you like
checking your pulses
you're kind of doing some medical
examinations do i look okay
is my color bad you know it's like
yeah it's strange but i'll tell you what
doing a will is a strange thing
let's just say anybody for anybody we're
all gonna die that's one thing we can't
count on
got to do a well you got to get on
mamabear.com get your will done for sure
everybody's going to die you got to get
a will and um
it's a but it's a sobering exercise it
reminds us of our mote
of our mortality this is the dave ramsey
[Music]
shout
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices and they make it
simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
what would it be like to have no credit
card debt no
medical bills no student loans
no car payments the borrower's slave to
the lender how would you feel if you
were free
how much better would you feel after
2020 most of america feels the same way
stressed and out of control but this
year really can be different it is time
it's time to take control of your money
and the best way to do that is the
ramsey plus
money reset it is our challenge
for anyone that wants to start ramsey
plus this year how much
progress can you make on your money if
you went
all in game on for 90 days
all into paying off your debt all into
saving for emergencies with ramsey plus
we're going to give you
daily and weekly
and monthly small wins with your money
and they add up to be
really big so this year you can just
decide
to reset your money to go all in for 90
days and take control of your money make
today
day one start a free trial
at ramsey plus go to daveramsey.com
it is time open phones this hour
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
laurel is with us in richmond oregon hi
redmond oregon hi laurel how are you
i'm fabulous how are you your phone
sucks great what's up
um i invested some money for my daughter
can you speak direct i can't understand
you can you speak directly into your
phone please
[Music]
how's that a little better thanks
um i invested some money for my daughter
to get when she's 35.
she's now 35 getting the money but the
housing market
seems to be not in very good situation
to buy a home
so my question is should she reinvest
the money that she's getting on the
annuity or should she
buy a home at this point why would it
not be a good time to buy a home
well the prices in central oregon are
astronomical they are everywhere
so do you just pay it or reinvest it
down i think you're going to have long
wait
like never yeah i mean the market may
soften and you may get a deal at some
point
if you know if the economy gets screwed
up or something but i'm not going to
wait around to buy a home at 35 years
old
uh you buy now you don't want to go out
and overpay in the sense that you just
you know get in some bidding war or
something crazy where you're overpaying
for a property you want to be diligent
about purchasing a property but
uh she's 35 it's her money she'll be
able to make this decision
yeah i you know you can't sit there and
try to time this out you know the
market's hot
and uh it's all about supply demand so
all you do is look at your local
situation and and and make a decision at
some point you gotta you gotta buy and
you make the best purchase possible and
then you you
you move forward yeah my 35 year olds
don't ask me
yeah there's and i'm dave ramsey i was
wondering if we were going to address
that i mean
you know you're 35 yeah she gets to do
what she wants to do yeah
give her advice and stuff you know if
they ask me it's it's because they
actually want my advice uh what do you
think about the market right now and
that kind of a thing but i don't
dictate to them when they're 35 years
old
we see a lot of this you know this is
this is a helicopter
situation where as parents you got to be
careful you got to at some point
trust them and let them learn and give
them some advice and walk away yeah that
point was a decade ago yeah
nisha is in boise idaho hi nisha how are
you
hi dave and ken great thank you for
everything you do thank you
dave my husband and i are coordinating a
fpu class at the moment and
we have one participant who has been
with her husband since she was
19. she's now in her 40s and five months
ago her husband left her
and she's never handled any of the
finances
she just got served with divorce papers
but she only has sixteen hundred dollars
to her name
her income is pretty limited my
understanding is that there's a lawyer
that she can hire for five
thousand dollars that is the so-called
pitfall that would get her everything
she needs
or she could hire another lawyer for
1500.
i know idaho's a 50-50 state when it
comes to divorce
but what's your advice for her and how
would she
how would she create the 5 000 to hire
the best lawyer
why has she not gotten her income up
during the five months he's been gone
um she's she's been um a stay-at-home
mom for a long time so i think that's
the best she can do right now she is she
does have two jobs
um one is actually in a school so i
think it's limited income
just because of the school year
but here's my point um he's
wait a minute is he is he like do they
have a lot of money is he wealthy
um he's definitely better off than she
is he's
um it sounds like he's being quite
manipulative at the moment
um and holding all the money back that
would be theirs yeah but what is
all the money i mean how much money does
he have is
hundreds of thousands of dollars this
pit bull for five thousand dollars is
not going to create money where there's
not money
right i i would have to say he works um
for the federal government i would have
to say he's got quite a bit set aside
that she doesn't know about because
she's never had anything to do with the
finances in all the years that they've
been together
okay but we you don't really have any
indicator of that except that he's had a
decent career and he hides and
manipulates
right and you know he just bought a
brand new mercedes he's
just um getting ready to build a new
house okay i'm going after him
[Laughter]
so what are her two jobs what are the
two jobs that she's been working these
are two part-time jobs i'm assuming
yes uh you know well one's in the school
so i guess it's only eight months out of
the year
um and then the other one is an evening
job that she does after she's
you know got home said her children and
then when the kids go together yes
they're a little older they're 18 and
14. oh good okay
okay so here's the deal she is has a
um a broken heart
and her confidence what she had has been
crushed
yes and that is the bigger crisis here
than anything else
and so we've got to get her eyes
on the 10 years from now at 52. she's a
successful dot dot dot
fill in that blank very successful
making more money than he makes now
and she's going to because she's going
to be she's going to be a caterpillar
that becomes a beautiful butterfly
how many people are in your group how
many people are in your group that
you're coordinating
we're only a group of so there's just
myself and my husband and three other
people okay but that's a start that's a
base
so one of the best things you can do for
her is playing off what dave just said
is remind her of that
and say hey we're going to come
alongside of you in this deal and we're
gonna help you get a better job
or a better two jobs because if you just
take
the amount of people that the three
couples okay know
and you expand that out and you begin to
help share her narrative and share her
story because the other thing that she's
dealing
with is she's been a stay-at-home mom
for so long and i get these calls on the
ken coleman show all the time and they
think
well life has passed me by and that's
not true the fact of the matter is she
has tangible hard skills and soft skills
that she can use
and if it were me nisha you said what
should we do let's help her get a better
job a better paying job that's going to
give her more money which is going to
give her some breathing room
it's going to give her some momentum and
some confidence and that's how she saves
for the five thousand dollar pit bull
but i would walk with her on this and on
top of that
you you tell her sit down with a pit
bull and say i got 1500 i'll have the 5
000 later or you can take it out of his
height if you'd like that'd be great
how about it go over there and get some
of that money
and i'll give you your 5 000 that's
right by the way those guys
if he's really a pit bull he'll respond
to that he'll like that yeah
yeah and you do want that guy you want
the one that wants to take a chunk out
of the guy's butt
right yeah that that's how i was leaning
also
yep yeah that i think you get him going
but but you're going to jack him up
she's not going to have the 5 000
but but more than anything what the fact
that she has not got
her career moving better than it is
over a five month period of time tells
me
that she's still under the blanket
of the depression of this toxicity of
this marriage and we've gotta
we gotta get her wings out of this
cocoon and get them out there where she
can flap them
because she's gonna she's gonna need
income regardless of the divorce
regardless how much she gets from the
guy she's got to have a beautiful better
life and so she needs king coleman in
her life big time
yeah and hang on kelly i'll pick up
we'll send you a copy of ken's book just
for her
[Music]
[Music]
you know healthcare has gotten to be
ridiculous
it puts people um you know on the brink
and so it would have put us on the brink
had we not had
ca gm chm saved our life same driving
financial lives
christian healthcare ministries or chm
is not health insurance
but it is a budget friendly option and
the original health cost sharing
ministry for christians
learn more today and check us out at
chministries.org
that's chministries.org
[Music]
[Applause]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
825-5225
cheryl is with us in canada hi cheryl
how are you
[Music]
hi thanks for taking my call sure what's
up i have a question
regarding um my husband and i are
debating about whether we should sell
our 1995
tent trailer and upgrade to a used
travel trailer we're in our mid-30s we
have a family of six that loves to camp
we're debt-free including our home and
we have cash to pay both for the trailer
and the tow vehicle that we would need
to pull it
but i'm really concerned about the steep
depreciation and the other costs the
storage
maintenance the insurance so we want to
get your opinion about whether it's wise
to make this purchase
okay what's it gonna cost
um depending on the age if we get a
five-year-old trailer it'd be about
twenty-two thousand
um if we go back to a 15 year old
trailer we're talking maybe
10 000 less 12 000 but it could need
more maintenance as well
okay and what are the costs associated
with owning it
we're estimating it would cost about
three thousand dollars including the
depreciation and storage the insurance
but that's not including depreciation on
an suv that we would buy
that includes the depreciation what's
that what's the cash
what's the cash out of pocket to own the
thing after you own it
not counting depreciation
um yearly it would be about 800 for
storage and insurance
what's your household income about 200
000
okay what are your car what's the other
vehicles that you own what's the value
on all of those
um so we have a i would say about 20
000 together we have a car in a van i
would buy it
you would buy it okay it just has a very
steep depreciation and it just feels
like a
toy that's exactly what my husband would
really love to try a complete waste of
money
that's exactly what it is yes except for
the fact that you're going to use it for
making memories with your family and
you're going to get enjoyment out of it
yeah are you planning to flip it anytime
anytime soon no of course not that's my
point so i mean the depreciation is
almost like a false narrative in this
decision
the thing is this here's how i decided
that okay you want
here's the decision making tool i use
cheryl it is
okay you will have 50 000
or less tied up in things that are going
down in value with
wheels and motors you make two hundred
okay if we set fifty thousand dollars in
the middle of the table
in your financial situation and set fire
to it
you're still okay yes
it'll be unpleasant but you're still
okay
and so the problem with toys is if you
told me all that and then you told me
you made 50 grand
i would be going you're out of your
freaking mind you cannot absorb
depreciation on 40 or 50 000 worth of
stuff when you make 50 grand
because it is all going down in value
you've accurately
assessed that but you're a hundred
percent debt free house and everything
you make 200
000 a year you got great control of
everything you've researched everything
to the t
you've really know your stuff you're not
wandering into this
undisciplined you're not wandering into
this on an impulse
you've thought this through you even
called to ask an expert's opinion this
is how much
detail you've gone into and the numbers
10 years from today in your overall
wealth building tool are irrelevant
and that's how you decide if you can
have a toy or not
right that makes a lot of sense i think
we're just
real savers yeah i think you are i think
you're tight-wise you're very
disciplined but again 800
is what you've estimated it's going to
cost you an upkeep and i don't think
that's a willy-nilly
number either so you just got to play
that out what does 800 dollars mean to
you in your budget
and you're current it's nothing it's
peanuts in your current
most people buying a biscuit yeah
i mean there could be maintenance costs
that could really add up as well
um so there are a lot of you could
forget to pay the insurance and the
thing rolls off a cliff and you're and
you lose the whole thing and you still
it's 22
dollars you're all right yeah
in your world twenty two thousand
dollars does not destroy your world
if you spend twenty two thousand dollars
on let's try it this way
if you spent twenty two thousand dollars
remember back when they had these things
called cruises
if you spent twenty two thousand dollars
to take your family on a cruise
and came home with nothing but the
memory you can afford to do that
you can afford that
we could yeah another element of this
equation is that
i i'm self-employed i'm a contractor and
while my husband brings home the bulk of
the income and i'm part-time
working from home um my my income does
fluctuate and so
you know we could we could be down 30
000 from that average from last year
cheryl you're having trouble enjoying
the fruits of your labor
it's a new it's a new skill you need to
practice you're you you enjoy
saving and you enjoy planning and you
enjoy analyzing
but you're getting paralysis of the
analysis it's a 22 000
purchase and in your world it's not a
big deal
and you're you're making a whole lot
bigger you're trying to find something
to worry about here darling
yeah go get your trailer and enjoy it
yeah take your kids camping out in the
woods
you're gonna have a place no one else go
out there and just sit back there and
get you a cup of coffee and smile in the
camping chair
i mean the maintenance on this is not
going to be that much unless somebody's
walking around that thing beating it
with uh
you know sledge hammers then we got real
problems but the mainness of this they
can absorb that well yeah
it's not again set fire to it
and get you another one that's right
it's not it's not the end of the world
right and so the good news this is what
happened what's
what's happening with her happens with
all of us it's happened to me
it's happened to you as we progress in
the math
our emotions don't always keep up that's
true there's still
a part of when i get ready to buy
something today today
sharon ramsey will often times say
some sentence and you've actually you
and stacey have been sitting there
sometimes when she'll say it i've seen
it yeah
and but it it the the sentence has
nothing to do with her present reality
it has to do
with a 28 year old version of her who's
in bankruptcy court where the starbucks
with a baby
wasn't starving but without worrying
about feeding our babies
and that that person still lives inside
of her
inside of me yes and we all have that
whether you've been through bankruptcy
or not but this these folks have been
saving and
progressing and their their reality has
progressed
so much beyond their emotional yes
grasp of it and that happens to all of
us everybody i mean we spend more on
copier paper and coffee in this building
oh yeah than i used to make in a year
yeah i've heard you say i can't i can't
get my head around
their checks are right out of ramsey how
about this building i mean
they blow your mind when you wrote the
checks for this building
it becomes surreal it becomes kind of
like like you're playing monopoly
right or something with somebody else's
money but that's the the
but we've often talked about inside the
business and in our personal lives that
as
we have become progressively wealthier
and and more successful in general
our emotions still remind us of the
other stuff
it's a good check and balance because
you don't really good this keeps cheryl
or people all of us when we're in
cheryl's situation from overspending
so she's being very wise this is not to
pick on her at all no
and you know the best part of her story
is she she is a
uh detailed fiend i mean she's she's on
the research yeah you know what this was
about this had nothing to do with
details this was dave
please tell me that we're not being
careless yeah it's the psychology of the
money and that's what you've been
describing that's what changes
yep you know when you and sharon you
talked about staffing the other day you
know the way you had to change your life
and the way that to this day but you
said the other day you still give
sharing envelopes
oh she still hasn't she don't know
there's a whole it's a lot bigger
envelope yeah probably a lot more in it
a little thicker
but the fact of the matter is that life
change comes with psychology first
because you're surviving yeah and you're
just buckling down
then then you get into thriving but the
habits
and the way you see money it's still
there
and it feels so weird you're like oh my
gosh this is an abs
of this is a ridiculous amount of money
to spend on a trailer getting ready to
buy something that you
when somebody else bought it years ago
you looked at them and said i would
never that's right i will never spend
that
on a car 22 000 on a depreciating asset
instead of going
never we've lived like no one else and
sure again
this is this is this is saying you're
smart you're wise
yes uh that you're not gonna blow it
you're not gonna blow it trust your
instincts
uh except but but the only advice i've
got for you is just
in you know push against a little bit
and yeah
embrace the reality of where you are not
where you came from
yes and that allows you to enjoy
generosity yes and it allows you to
enjoy
being generous to yourself in the
process buy a huge box of marshmallows
the same day that you buy the camper and
some graham crackers
that too and some chocolate you got to
make some s'mores
[Music]
[Music]
so
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
host of the ken coleman show where we
talk about careers he's america's
leading career coach
on 70 radio stations across america plus
podcast
plus siriusxm be sure and tune in and
youtube
and youtube that's right can't forget
about that yeah
because i mean you and i are known for
our
quality camera appearances yes
we probably should stick to radio but
you know you have to expand
you have to you have to embrace the
modern day people are i'm telling you
all right car harley is with us in
cincinnati hey carly how are you
god dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
okay so um just a little bit of
background um i'm 23 years old and still
living at home with my parents
i graduated cosmetology school in 2016
but i ended up leaving the salon life to
explore
other options with steadier incomes i
took a job two years ago with a
logistics company
doing billing the pay is really low i
get 13
an hour at full time so last year was
about 26
000. um i'm debt free after paying off
35 000 in school loans and car debt good
for you mike
thank you my question is more so advice
i'm wanting to move out on my own
soon now that i'm debt-free and actually
i was planning on
moving down to tennessee um i'm seeking
advice on finding a
new job or career that pays enough for
me to be able to support myself does the
cosmetology degree does it transfer from
state to state is it reciprocal
it does not um just just ohio
let me i'm sorry you're kidding me you
got trained to cut hair and license to
cut hair
in ohio and tennessee does not respect
that license
no i would have to retake my board test
for tennessee
just the board test but not the school
right yeah okay well how big a deal is
that
um i would have to refresh my training
um
in education and then
sign up to i think it's uh i think it
costs money to take your boards but i'm
not sure i'm sure it
yeah it does sure it does but why would
you have to refresh just go take it you
just took it
yeah in uh 2016 i did the question is
what do you
the question is what kind of work do you
want to do because when somebody says
well what kind of work
would allow me to make good money that's
an open-ended question i could answer
that
uh for 24 hours straight you know a job
a j-o-b
is a j-o-b but i don't i don't teach
people that they're put on this planet
to just work a j-o-b
work is not a utilitarian function so
what is it that you
really want to do you've got a creative
you're 23 where do you want to be when
you're 40 years old yeah
what's that what's something that gets
you excited about that fires your heart
up
um the reason i actually went into
cosmetology wasn't to work in salons it
was to work
doing like backstage theater or um
like movie production that type of stuff
um you just need a salon experience to
get into that
however i've since done a lot of
research on getting into that and it's
very hard
and also you have to be in a union to
even be able to legally be paid to work
on jobs like that
are you talking about doing are you
talking about doing makeup in the in the
entertainment industry
yes sir okay all right keep going i'm
sorry you were saying
so you have to pay to get into a union
for that to get paid to do it legally so
i've been
um back in ohio i've just been doing
like a full-time job and then doing the
um the cosmetology stuff on the side so
i'll like pick up weddings when i can
i don't know if you know what kings
island is i've worked for the past five
years for
um i've done makeup for them for the
past five years for their
halloween haunt and winterfest stuff all
right so here's let me let me just break
this down for you because you need to be
able to look up and see what's the
long-term play here
and i can tell you unequivocally that
you can do very well
as a makeup artist in the entertainment
industry and start to break into
you know not just the entertainment
industry but you know like for instance
ramsay solutions hires makeup artists
when we do
a different union requirement there's no
union requirement so there's a that's a
myth that you have to be a union member
to be a successful cosmetologist or
makeup artist and you can do
very very well now it's a it's just like
any other industry you got to get in
and then once you're in once you're on
that ladder carly now we can begin to
climb the ladder and that's why i wrote
this book called the proximity principle
and here's what the proximity principle
is
it just says this in order to do what
carly wants to do to be a professional
makeup artist
she's got to be hanging around
professional makeup artist
people that are doing it and then she's
got to be in places where it's happening
so that means online communities and and
associations and i'm gonna show up in
some places where it's happening and i'm
gonna volunteer
where they need an extra set of hands
sometimes and i may not get paid at a
couple of these gigs
but i'm meeting people because i'm in
the right places and if you stay with it
long enough
you'll get there so you can get going
part time
as you've been showing and you've
already proven it to us doing some
makeup artist work if you want to move
to tennessee
then you get a couple of jobs you keep
busting it
these are day jobs and we get the money
to move to tennessee so it's an easy
transition
we make some connections before we move
to tennessee and we get going but you
can start in this part time and
eventually you'll get in
full time and do very very well but
number one you don't have to join a
union
but you're gonna have to get you're
gonna have to get anchored and nashville
is a hot area for this
and as covid begins to kind of thaw out
and all this stuff
people get back you're going to see a
roar you're going to see a
boom dave in these entertainment jobs
and in the entertainment industry and
she needs to be positioned
and she needs to be positioned
professionally and getting here and
getting the state boards taken to be
ready to go
and ready to ready for action and making
connections i'm available i'll come do
this
this is just a game of attrition dave
it's not a difficult play but we've got
to put ourselves in the right place
stay there keep showing up keep
connecting keep doing a great job
and as you know when i was doing radio i
had a full-time job
and i was doing radio on saturdays and
that's the deal you've got to stay
with it this radio show lost money for
the first 10 years it was on the air
yes and the other parts of the business
were our day job so to speak were um
were supporting it
now it makes a lot of money but it
didn't used to that's right
and um so it's not unusual to do this
not unusual
um you know in in the entertainment
field it is all about
connectivity uh the proximity principles
is a big deal so we'll send you a copy
of ken's book on that
and get you going carly uh brad is with
us brett is in long beach hey brett
welcome to the dave ramsey show
hey dave thanks for having me sure man
what's up
um i just wanted to check with you so
i'm following the dead steps and i'm on
step number two now trying to pay off
all my debts
and i want to see if it's why i need to
do a cash flow refine my condo
in order to pay off my student loan no
because you're not paying it off you're
just moving it on to your condo
okay and even though the interest rate
might be lower on my condo that doesn't
make any sense
nope you're changing something that you
should pay off in a couple of years and
it's something you're gonna pay off in
15 to 30.
so how much student loan debt have you i
got
36 000 left what's your household income
i make 92 000 a year so why can't you
pay that in a year
uh well i got a truck payment
and it's i'm slowly chipping away at it
but
you owe on your truck i owe 19 000
okay and how much other data have you
got not counting the condo
that's it okay all right
so you have 55 000 in debt and you make
90.
well for sure you should be debt-free in
two years that'd be 27
500 out of 90 a year
how much is the truck worth the
truck um well i bought it for 25 000
2016 colorado i'd find out how much it's
worth is it just you you single
yeah yeah i might step down out of that
and that'll help you get things moving
too because you've got a big momentum
there but here's the thing
what you're not doing brad i can tell
based on these numbers you're not doing
a written detail budget where you're
making every dollar behave
you've not quit eating out you've not
gotten into
attack mode on this debt you're not
squeezing
the money that you have because 90 000
should be able to live even in long
beach uh
and still come up with 30 000 a year to
become debt free in two years
and keep the truck in that case but no
you cannot borrow your way out of debt
there's no short-term goal there's no
short-term
quick easy way out of debt and borrowing
on your condo to move it around
doesn't mean you know and and calling it
a wise move because of interest rate
did not make the debt go away what makes
the debt go away is you're getting on
top of it with your foot and standing on
its neck
yeah you can do this man you're just
gonna have to get really intense and
now's the time when you're single you
have anybody relying on you get after it
yeah it is
this is your call to really get very
detailed and very serious as if your
life depends on it
because your financial life does it's
time
it's time hold on i'm gonna send you a
copy of the total money makeover book to
help you with it
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be intentional about your character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the dave ramsey
show
where dad is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host this is your show
america thank you for
joining us open phones at 825-5225
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
you jump in and we'll talk triple eight
eight two five
five two two five lauren is with us in
greensboro north carolina hi lauren
welcome to the show
hey dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
hey so i'm getting married this summer
and
once i move into my future husband's
house um
i plan to use my rent money to either go
towards
helping pay down the mortgage or putting
towards savings
to our next house which we planted by
two to three years after we're married
you know i just want to see what the
best option is and neither of us have
any debt except the house
great very cool well uh we would change
how we're
approaching it and then that'll help you
figure out what's going on it's no
longer your rent money
we now have a budget that is our
income if we have any extra income and
you will have
in your budget what are we going to do
with our extra income
and that's a different way of
approaching it because it should be more
than just your old rent
okay gotcha okay so you see the
difference in the terminology because it
matters
because when you're working a plan
together if you say i'm just going to
take that rent money and do something
with it
that limits you and it causes you to
continue to think
separately rather than unified with the
person you're marrying
okay okay all right so uh what are we
gonna do with our extra money we're
always gonna put it
ramsey's always gonna tell you to put it
on your next baby step where you are
now baby step three is your new
household
should have three to six months of ma of
expenses saved as an emergency fund
will that already be done yes
okay good then your new household is
going to look at your total household
income
upon being married and say we're going
to save
15 of our income going into retirement
as a budget item and then that's going
to lower
or affect how much you have to move on
with other things
do either one of you have children that
you're bringing into this marriage
no okay so baby step five is save for
college you don't need to do that
so the answer to your overall question
after i give you all my clarifications
and caveats
is pay it on the house
that's baby step six we're gonna get rid
of the home mortgage but this is the two
of you working together to achieve that
goal
and of course you're gonna have some
other things you need to do in this
budget
with a combined household you're going
to want to
you know purchase a new couch you're
you're moving into his house and it
probably needs a touch from you
i highly suggest the touch whether he
thinks he needs it or not
i'll guarantee you he doesn't think he
does and i'll guarantee you he does
yeah i was curious lauren uh how much is
his house worth
any idea how much debts on it
um get probably
the 100 thousand range i think
uh upwards of 200 000 for
values right right so what what do you
make and what's he make
well combined will probably make her a
little over 105
excellent that's great excellent you
guys are going to be in great shape
and so i gave you a lot of detail there
to try to get things
lined up the right way and all kidding
aside he is going to experience
something that all husbands
since time began have experienced um and
that is that there's a line item in the
budget called redecorating
yes yes and it really is because
his house pro the reality is his house
probably needs it right
my son got married two years ago he had
the homies living
living in for a couple years and it
needed it needed allison's touch i'm
just saying
and allison put her touch on it they
lived there a couple more years and sold
it and made a lot of money and moved on
up to another property but
um it sure did help it when allison
moved in i'm just saying yeah and i want
to say this to you lauren
uh i'm i'm approaching 23 years of
marriage dave's been married longer than
me
uh listen it is a temptation for all
young couples
to want to progress and to uh start this
new life and upgrade upgrading house
there's nothing wrong with it you guys
are so sharp
and you're in great shape but i'm just
going to tell you just going to play a
little older brother on you
you need to pay that house off you only
owe about 100 105 on it
you guys with that joint income pay it
off completely
get that thing and then now you sell
that house
and think about the house you can
actually buy with a massive
massive down payment so just be patient
love it love it love it love it
all right jake is with us in wichita
kansas hi
jake welcome to the dave ramsey show hey
thank you how are you guys
better than we deserve what's up so
um my fiance is 35 000 in debt and i was
wondering
whether i should try to pay off that now
or pay after the
wedding after the wedding
after the wedding never pay someone
else's debt until you're married
always pay their debt as soon as you
come home from the honeymoon yeah
that makes me nervous what's that julia
roberts wedding where she keeps running
at runaway bride
makes me very nervous paying off 35 000.
yeah so you got cash you got the cash to
pay it off
uh not all of it um and actually 30 000
of it is a school loan
that we don't have to start paying on
until about another year and a half oh
it doesn't matter pay it off anyway
pay it off soon as you get married so
how much uh when are you getting married
uh we're getting married the 31st of
july awesome
congratulations it's awesome yeah oh
thank you that's so fun
it's so cool that you're able to step in
and you guys are able to join your
finances and accomplish some goals
really quick like that
because you knocked out that debt and
really fast then you're going to be able
to move on to other stuff as young as
you are you're going to really be doing
well
yeah well we're really lucky that we
found you i just started listening to
the podcast
last week uh and just finished baby step
one and so i was taking a crack at baby
step two and just thought i should
try to figure out where i should start
yeah so have you got any that
no no debt okay so baby step two for you
doesn't exist you're moving on to
finishing up your emergency fund right
right and then you move on and you i
wouldn't start your investing i just
pile that money up and get ready for
july
i wouldn't do your baby step four right
now i would just pile up and get get
ready to write the check when you marry
her because you want to knock out her
because all of a sudden you're going to
start right back over again in july
right
right so yeah let's just pile up cash
and get ready for that
from a practical or a tactical
standpoint
and uh you're luckier than that you're
luckier than finding us on youtube
because you're not only that you got
through on these phones which is a
dadgum
lottery and on top of that uh we're
going to
give you a wedding gift we want you to
be in ramsey plus which is financial
peace university
premium version of every dollar
everything you need to really
this is the bentley of handling money
we're going to show you how to do it i'm
going to give you a one-year
subscription
as a wedding gift jake so hang on and
kelly will pick up and we'll take care
of you guys on that what a great way to
start
yeah these young couples that are
getting ahead of the game marriage is
the first year of marriage is really
tough is you learn to live with somebody
else and you learn to actually
get out of the in love stage and
actually love and and have to learn how
to love when you don't like and
to have the no money it takes a year of
being you don't buy a house in the first
year it takes a year of being married to
know how close to your mother-in-law
you threw me off there dave when you did
the wedding gift i didn't see ramsay
plus coming i thought what do we have
some knives
a blender i didn't know where you were
going with that so i was like oh okay
that makes more sense
send them ken's blender okay
[Laughter]
yes we'll we'll send that just free of
charge i'm ready for a new
throw that in yeah the one that's back
there in the room that he makes his
juice with
yes yeah there we go there we go that's
always good
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help get you there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five well after 2020 some
of you are saying i need to
better plan the one i had doesn't
prepare me for
pandemics doesn't set me up to win you
need a
reset so in 2021 we're helping you do a
reset
and uh you can take control of your
money you need a plan you need the right
plan ramsey plus is our step-by-step
plan that'll help you get some quick
wins daily wins
weekly wins a 90-day challenge
all to get you started because you
really
never mess up by getting a great fast
start
you can decide on their total money
reset this year start with ramsey plus
it includes financial peace university
it includes every dollar it includes the
baby step
tracking app it includes ask a coach
app it includes all the stuff to help
you everything you need to do
to get moving with the money and execute
the plan you hear us talking about here
every day here
it is there's a free trial jump into
ramsey plus for a free trial
by going to daveramsey.com
reset daveramsey.com
reset this is the dave ramsey show ken
coleman
is with me as my co-host today kevin is
in austin texas
hi kevin how are you i'm doing good how
are you guys better than i deserve
what's up
all right my question may be more for
ken uh i just got your book the
proximity principle and i'm starting to
read through it i'm about two chapters
in
and it feels like this book is geared
toward providing
help for people who know where they want
to be what they want to do but don't
know how to get there
so i'm in a little bit of a predicament
because i'm not entirely sure
what i want to be where i want to go
i'm struggling to find uh i guess that
direction so my
my question is do you have any advice on
how to soul search and figure out what
i should be doing yeah well there's a
simple process that i teach in stage one
of my seven stages to meaningful work
it's called get clear and you need to
get clear
and what you do is you look for the
clues with the three gifts that your
creator has given you talent passion and
mission
and i define those as talent you know
what that means it's simply what you do
best
and i'm not talking about your fives and
sixes i mean your seven eights nines as
you look at your
you know soft skills and hard skills and
passion is defined as work you love
these are tasks
functions a role that you enjoy engaging
in and then mission is the results of
that work that has a deep connection to
your heart
now we don't have time to walk through
all of that i've got a great career
clarity guide that is a
a free resource for you that i want you
to walk through
and i ask all the questions in this
guide it's free at ken coleman.com but
let's try to fast forward because when
somebody like you talks
uh to me and says i i'm not completely
sure that means you've got some ideas
i want you to tell me what you've
wondered about like almost like a child
with childlike wonder what would it be
like if i did this
for for work what what is something
you've dreamed about or wondered about
uh well i i feel like i have a acumen
for leadership
and for uh people um so i
and i'll tell you my dad's a pastor
and so i've i've had the thought often
of what would it look like for me to go
into ministry
um why haven't you pursued that there's
something that has held you back what is
it naaman is clear
and as plain as you can
hesitancy to maybe what other people
think i don't know
he did it because his dad did it i don't
know all right so let me ask you a
question so my dad's a pastor too just
retired actually
last year from 47 years in the ministry
so that's my whole life and
i married a preacher's daughter as well
i believe that if you can keep from
being a pastor you should
that's what my dad told me because i was
the pastor's kid i loved to speak i
loved to communicate i was always on a
stage
and now i've gone into public
communication as my work
but my dad said son he said if you can
keep from it
and what he was saying was the call to
ministry
is clearly a spiritual call i believe
all work is is honorable and of the lord
but
he said if you can keep from it keep
from it but what i've heard from you is
you're worried about what other people
are going to say because your dad's a
pastor so the question is
if we removed all of that do you believe
at this point in your life kevin
as honestly as you can be right now do
you believe that that you were called to
ministry forget about being a senior
pastor what the role is just
ministry as it it relates to a
profession do you believe you're called
to that
no i i don't think so okay then i want
to release you from that
and so the reality is as we look at what
was it about it that was
appealing to you and maybe that like ken
like he he this stage and public
communication
but not pastoring so the thing that
could have been he could have confused
those two i think the part that was
appealing to me was the uh
you know how you help people you know
and yeah and obviously we're called to
personal evangelism i mean what girls
all of us are that yeah well you gave us
a clue you want to lead people
but you don't have to lead them in a
ministry context why do you want to lead
people
if let's just say that i've had to snap
my fingers and i put you in a leadership
position today
okay and you couldn't fail why do you
want to lead people what's the why
in one sentence say it from your heart
oh man to help people to get us where we
need to go you know to establish a
vision and to take us there you know to
accomplish great things
okay so let me ask you this where would
you let's just have some fun i don't
want you get hung up on the specifics
but i want you to just think if you
could lead a team of people
to produce results anywhere any sector
anywhere in the world what kind of
results do you want to lead a team to
produce
because this is at the heart of this
what results do you want to produce in
the world and you're leading a team to
make
those results a reality hi you know can
i
i'm struggling i don't know all right
okay here's the deal it's okay
you're on the doorstep but here's what i
want you to i want you to wrestle with
three questions
okay and then i want you if you want to
i want you to call back my show
the ken coleman show all right and you
can call between 12 and 2 eastern
standard time monday through friday
we'll get you through
i want you to answer these three
questions that are in the career clarity
guide that's free that i want you to
download at kencoleman.com i want you to
really focus on mission
and you answer these questions who are
the people i most want to help what's
the problem i most want to solve
and what are the solutions to those
problems that i want to be a part of see
leadership is service
leadership is leading a team in a bigger
organization
to solve a problem that's way bigger
than us as the leader
and i will tell you that some other
advice i want you to answer those
questions
and you'll begin to see oh i want to
create these results in the marketplace
and once we determine the results we
want to create in the marketplace we
find organizations that are doing that
and we say do they align with our values
and then i want to get in because here's
the key
and young people hear me that you want
to lead you cannot
lead until you learn how to follow i
want you to get an organization
and work and be a follower and be a team
player
and study leadership read entre
leadership dave's number one
best-selling book
listen to the entre leadership podcast a
world-class podcast from ramsey
solutions
read leadership books read john maxwell
i used to work for john he was a mentor
of mine
read the 360 degree leader consume
leadership
books watch great leaders emulate them
and then you keep following and then if
you keep doing a great job you'll get
promoted eventually into the opportunity
to lead but as far as where to lead just
go find an organization
that is producing results that matter to
you in the marketplace don't overthink
it
yeah michelle kelly when he picks up get
the phone number for madison uh ken's
producer
so they can do a follow-up call on
kent's show yeah i'd like to call it
after he's done his homework
she'll pick up and get that appointment
set for him that career clarity guide
day for folks that are listening
it walks them through that talent
passion mission exercise and they're not
under pressure on the air
then they can call me do it on the air
yeah yeah the
i'm curious if you think um with kevin
if if something that people tell him
he's good at or that he knows he's good
at you call that a talent yes
um does that give him a
hint or a clue
what the thing he's going to lead into
might be yeah
absolutely well what we want to see is
if he wants to lead we can
check it and we say do i have the skills
of communication
connecting with others do i have empathy
do i have the raw
talent to actually be a leader if you're
if you have if you're a young person and
you have a desire to be a leader
make sure that your desire to be a
leader is just that you don't want to be
a leader
simply to avoid being a follower that's
right it's not about authority it's
about influence yeah
that would be what you wrestle with
because it's a it's a
it's it's a privilege it's a weight yes
it is
heavy stuff it's you got to look at your
motive on that
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and
interior shutters with easy online
ordering free shipping and a guaranteed
perfect fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Music]
number one best-selling author radio
host and ramsey personality ken coleman
is my co-host today open phones at
triple eight
eight two five five two two five
allen is in ogden utah hey alan how are
you
i'm pretty good i'm having trouble
hearing you try again
uh so my fiance
is having trouble getting on board with
the idea of following the baby steps
and living the day of life
i've been listening to you guys for
probably about two years now and
i'm for the idea but it's really hard to
get going on it if you don't have a
partner who's on board
with you help me help her
understand what you're trying to sell
okay what is her problem with this idea
well she heard a one podcast
you guys did where this guy had that you
sold him
to sell it and buy something else
because it was it was sinking him and i
personally i saw the logic in what you
said
but what she didn't understand is why he
told him to ramp it up to 9
000 rather than keep it down at the like
three or five thousand dollars that he
was going to spend
that's not her problem and that's what i
tried to tell her
no that's not what she heard on a
podcast is not the problem
she was looking for an excuse to not do
this stuff when she's listening to the
podcast
so she found some little nuanced nothing
detail that doesn't even matter
to to have a reason to throw that's
right that was the idea of evidence that
dave is cuckoo so we can't do this
and that's there's plenty of evidence
that davis cuckoo it's fairly
fairly abundant not hard to find that if
you're looking for we provide it daily
yes we do it's here it's
15 000 hours of it in the last few years
but um
it's all on youtube by the way yeah but
yeah so
you know there's a lot of reasons to but
you know it's not a matter of me
as you know it's not it's not a personal
thing in the sense of
oh she doesn't like me that's not the
issue the the question
is that you guys have got the two of you
got to sit down and say okay
what are our goals
with money as a couple and what is the
best
method to get us to those goals
you see and i i love her to death but i
keep
living in debt and i can't keep living
paycheck to paycheck
that wasn't what i said that wasn't what
i said
you're not living in debt anyway because
you're not married
it's her problem if you leave her with
it uh if you get married now it's your
problem so as a precursor to getting
married
the two of you need to set a date
after you've gotten some good
pre-marriage counseling which it sounds
like you desperately need
and um and after you've sat down and
said
where okay how old are you guys
we are 30 and 31 okay when you say when
we're 55 years old
where do we want to be with our money
and what is the best
method to get there and you both then
answer that question and you say
hey i'd like to be out of debt and be
very wealthy
and be able to be very generous and be
able to travel
and be able to buy something and not
have to worry about it and this is what
you would say right
and then she can say whatever she wants
to say
and you say okay what is the best way to
get to this
dream and let's make sure our dreams are
combined before we combine
our lives yep allen i'm going to weigh
in here i want to go a little deeper
do you both have debt individually
yes she has about 12 000
worth of medical debt and i have about
a thousand dollars worth of consumer
debt okay
on a budget of about 20 000
a year okay but listen here's the thing
if if when you sit down with a marriage
counselor
in pre-marriage counseling and you say
what do you want to be
when we're 55 and she says oh i don't
know i just don't want anybody telling
me what to do
dude you're not marrying a woman you're
marrying a princess and you need to run
yeah that's what i'm getting at alan i
want to know why she's resisting
you need to know what her resistance is
to dave's thing and you can have it in
the same conversation and then i'd want
to know the why before you put before
you go down the aisle because
there is a there's something that she's
resisting
um in what you're telling her and you're
telling her how we teach
yeah and and it gets you where i would
assume
she would agree with the vision uh that
that you would want and so
this is so serious alan that i mean to
me
i i'd press pause on the engagement i'd
press pause on everything until you guys
got on the same page about what
you do i wouldn't do that i would just
get with a marriage counselor a
pre-marriage counselor immediately and
you guys began to talk
through
that's what i'm saying you need to but i
don't want to just break them up no
i don't mean that you know i think you
need to go and i don't mean that sit
down there
and um uh
you know sit down and try to work that
through um
and you know let let's figure out what
we're doing but
if at the end of the day i have been in
situations when i'm coaching couples
and one or the other of them uh
is like pounding their fists demanding
that
no limitations be put on them in any way
yeah
and that they're allowed to do whatever
they want to do and they they don't have
they're not accountable for the future
they're not accountable to themselves
much less their future spouse about
how we're going to end up then what
you've got there is someone throwing a
temper fit you've got a four-year-old
throwing a temper fit on the cereal
aisle because they can't get cheerios
and that this is not marriage material
no
and so that you know uh uh the old
joke is if a guy marries a girl who
loves spending money you better enjoy
making money but that's not true it
doesn't work that
doesn't you can't make enough to you
can't out earn
somebody who's a super spender yeah
you're playing them before they were
super
spreaders they were super spenders so
yeah right uh but yeah
yeah and i don't think this is what's
going on with her i think there's
something else i really don't
think she's a bad egg i don't either
that's why i want to know what's the
resistance
and why i want to know the why and it
could be too much
information it could be too that you
have used me as a weapon on her uh-oh
and turned me into a cuss word and
you've jammed up you've stopped up this
conversation
and constipated it and so you're going
to have you may have to just back away
from the dave thing because dave's not
relevant in this discussion
the two of you being on the same page
about a method of some kind
to get to where you want to be and being
on the same page on where you want to be
now that's vital huge i'm just going to
say it dave i mean you can correct me if
you think it's too strong i'm just
coming from the position
of watching couples and and if you
aren't on the same page about money
you're playing the marriage lottery
oh you and you're playing russian
roulette and the odds are so against you
number one cause of divorce of course
and it's money fights are money problems
so if you can't get on the same page
without money ahead of marriage don't
get married yeah
i don't think that's too strong okay but
i mean the number one people die
of a bear attack is walking down the
street don't walk down that street
you know i mean it's really common sense
you know good point so um you know the
bears are on that street they will kill
your butt you know i mean it's just like
so yeah this is not hard yeah and so um
yeah stay you know stay off of that and
um
you know i saw a statistic the other day
that uh uh
like 37 of the current divorces also
mentioned
a uh a spouse looking up an old
boyfriend or girlfriend on facebook
oh boy so the second leading cause of
divorce is facebook
right yeah so i'm good with getting rid
of that too yeah you should
yeah what could have been what are you
doing what are you doing
what are you doing going back i mean
come on now
yeah you just want to be satisfied
that's all
then you just go they didn't look at
that that's another problem
he lost all his hair look at that right
so yeah exactly
but uh anyway yeah so tr the all kidding
aside allen
it's imperative if you were my son or
daughter i would tell you it's
imperative
to be on the same page on religion
money in-laws and kids yes
with the help of a pre-marriage
counselor before you get married there's
all kinds of data and research that
shows those four things
are your leading indicators to a
fabulous
fabulous marriage one other little
nugget dave because i can't help it
alan if you do premarital counseling she
won't give in don't you give in
don't you do money the way you don't
want to do it
just to try to make her happy that ain't
gonna work either don't capitulate
yeah yeah we gotta come to agreement
yeah
not a concession that's what i wanted to
point out
this is the dave ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day is galatians 2
20 i have been crucified with christ it
is no longer i who live
but christ who lives in me and the life
i now live
in the flesh i live by faith in the son
of god
who loved me and gave himself for me
simon sinek says a leader must be
inspired by the people
before a leader can inspire
the people you know that's coming out of
simon right now we're seeing that out of
pat lincione and we're uh pat's new book
the motive
we're seeing it in the materials that
we're putting in entre leadership right
now
there seems to be something in the air
to remind
people that
leadership is not a position
with a corner office and a big paycheck
that you aspire to
it is a duty
it is a responsibility
and sometimes it comes with a paycheck
in a corner office
but if you're aspiring to the corner
office without the duty and without the
responsibility
um you're not going to end up being a
leader you're just going to be another
one of these
twerps you'll be an achiever a big deal
somebody worried about optics instead of
principles
that's right leadership is a conviction
because as a leader a true leader you
begin to understand wait a second i've
got a position
of authority and in some cases the
highest level of authority in where
you're leading
and yet it has nothing to do with
authority has everything to do with you
serving with you humbling yourself
and leading the team diving into the
problems taking the bullets
protecting guiding coaching
um you know correcting it's
it's uh it's a conviction you must
understand
too much heat the government leadership
there's too much
conflict and criticism that goes with
leadership
unless you are doing it as an as an act
of service
you'll quit or you'll acquiesce and you
just fall in and you go well i just got
it i'm worried about the way this looks
rather than doing the right thing that's
exactly what's the what's the right
thing yeah
you got to do the right thing and you
know you're the only one with all the
details
you got to do the right thing yeah not
what
some little piss ant says off to the
side somewhere yeah you're called to the
responsibility
of the being the people in that room
have the information
and you got you got to make the decision
then and knowing that when you make it
that you're going to piss people off
yeah and and making the right
the the principled call instead of the
call that makes people happy and
looks the way it should look one of my
favorite images of leadership
uh is from the movie we were soldiers
with mel gibson now he says i'm the
first one off the helicopter
and i'm the last one on and that's a
beautiful picture of what leadership is
yeah
that's exactly right when the bullets
are flying yeah you don't leave the
battlefield of the foxhole because
you've been shot at
no no no there's no retreat i've got men
that are relying on my
leadership in this moment it's you know
that's leadership but you better have a
conviction for it you better care about
the mission
you better care about the people or you
will not make it you will
you will not if i remember that was a
true battle and that was
represented in that movie oh absolutely
yeah yeah vietnam absolutely yeah
well i know vietnam happened but i'm
just saying that yeah i can't remember
the particular storyline was based on a
true story if i remember
yeah yeah yeah but uh military brings
that out
too some of you some of the most
honorable servant leaders i've ever met
in my life
are senior military officers there's a
nobility
on a military officer that's a good one
some of them are jerks
and some of them are self-centered just
like any group of leaders sometimes you
run into a twerp but
that i mean when i when we're on these
major installations these major bases
and we're speaking to the military teams
uh and helping their people and you walk
in and you're meeting a two-star
uh or or a you know a colonel or
whatever the the senior officer is in
that setting
uh you almost always meet someone that
there's a sense of calm uh
deliberate noble leadership and it's a
sense of responsibility
yes not a sense of oh i got the big job
that's it you just nailed it and uh i'm
not trying to be cheesy here just came
to me it's about the mission not
recognition
ooh leadership but that's good well i
know you
i know you don't like it when i rhyme
but i can't help but sometimes i never
made it as a wretched kid that's what it
is
but but but really that's it um like you
said david
it's about the mission and all those
military leaders they're always about
the mission it's not about
their their personal gain it's not about
their
authority their ego and and so you know
again
uh it's a great quote from from from
simon because it's like
look you got to be inspired by the
people that you're leading by what
they're doing the results they're trying
to drive
only then can you actually inspire them
yeah his second book simon second book
was leaders eat last yeah
great military context throughout the
entire title yeah great title on that
too
so yeah real leaders eat last or leaders
i think i'm gonna watch we were soldiers
tonight i might it's been a long time
since i've seen it just popped into my
head such a great movie
there you go yeah all right we're gonna
go with elise in detroit
michigan is up next hi elise how are you
hi dave and ken how are you guys better
than we deserve what's up
um so i have a question it's probably
okay
fascinating but long story short
my spouse and i are debt-free
we've got six months of emergency fund
savings
and we have a pretty good amount saved
for a house
and we're saving towards retirement
great um i yep so we
are i'm in the military so i appreciate
it everything that you were just saying
you agree with me i'm in the middle of
yes
i agree and i appreciated everything
that you were just talking about so
you're senior officers or if you're a
senior officer you run into some really
high class people there
yes yeah cool thank you for your service
by the way yes
so what's your question hello thank you
uh the question is so i'm
actually going to be getting out either
in next summer or the summer after
and once my income is gone
we probably won't be able to be saving
any money just on my spouse's income
because i'd like to be a stay at home so
the question is
we're unsure if we should purchase a
house
now with what we do have towards
an income or for a house or if we should
wait until later or have me try to stay
in longer
for four years um in order to
save up more for a house since we won't
have any
are you you're not planning on working
after the military
um we have a son who is about eight
months old
and we would really like for me to be
able to stay at home with him
okay but can you buy a home if you're
okay if you're staying home with him
can you guys afford a home on your
husband's income
well we would be able to have a lot to
put down
toward the house and we'd be able to pay
off like
the mortgage but we wouldn't be able to
have any
wiggle room of money so we're unsure if
that's a wise thing to do or not
a wiggle room if you pay off the house
why do you not have wiggle room
what's your husband make um
so his current income after tax is 36
000.
what's he do uh he works in supply chain
okay all right how old are you guys
we are 23. okay no rush to buy a house
i would say during the time that you're
planning on offloading your military
career
let's work on his career and let's say
what has to be true five years from
today for him to be making 75 000
instead of 36
right what's he going to be doing with
his life
that makes a whole lot more money than
he makes now there's nothing no shame in
making 36 especially if you're 23 years
old
but uh but i don't want him to be 32 in
making 36
and still wondering why you can't afford
a house so the point of that is
is that as his income trajectory changes
due to we're really focusing on his
career path
using some of ken coleman's materials
then that changes the answer on the
house
yep so you want to be in a big hurry on
the house
but we just are going to do it the right
way and you can be able to stay home
with a baby let's get his career going
and then let's get a house in the right
order but if you project 36 000 out for
10 years
then your your question the way you
framed your question makes sense but
that's not the right way to do it
yeah so good question thank you for
joining us ken thanks for hanging out
today thanks dave always fun
ken coleman the ken coleman show
everywhere great radio shows are heard
yes james charles is our producer kelly
daniel is our associate producer and
phone screener i am dave ramsey your
host we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
[Music]
you